now the link between constituency and mp
is obviously in sharp focus this weekend
not every former prime minister enjoyed
staying on the back benches after their
time in number 10 but gordon brown did
and he was there for a further five
years as mp for coccody and cowden beef
he joins me now from
fife
uh good morning uh gordon brown
do you
have a memory of
david amos
yes my first thoughts of course are with
his widow julia and their five children
this is a terrible tragedy i remember
david entered the same same time as me
to the house of commons
i think he was the person i remember
most because almost every question and
every speech he made he always mentioned
the name of his constituency and that
shows just how much he was in touch with
his local community hard hard-working
determined caring compassionate we've
heard all this that emphasizes just what
a good man of the people he actually was
and this is beyond partisanship
you've got to pay respects to someone
who really
died doing something that he enjoyed
most which was listening to
consulting
uh helping
serving his constituents and i will
remember him as a as a great
constituency mp as i know everybody else
will who is in the house of commons
today
also
what of course has emerged in the
discussion of the aftermath of this
dreadful event
is the
relationship between
the member of parliament and the
constituency
is there a danger that we now find
ourselves
willingly
having the culture of our democracy in
some way eroded because of because
public figures have to retreat behind a
wall of security of some kind
yet trevor trevor this is an attack on
our democracy
so the answer cannot be less democracy
this looks as if it is a terrorist
incident
it is probably related to al-shabaab or
to al-qaeda and we'll find out more in
the next few days
but the answer when you come across a
terrorist incident
is we don't blink we don't shirk we
don't flinch we don't show weakness
we stand up for what we believe
and of course we will increase the
security that is available to members of
parliament and councillors when they're
doing the surgeries and that is
something that must happen immediately
but it's true also to say that we must
not allow our democracy to be diminished
because the terrorist attack has
occurred i think the history of dealing
with terrorism is that if you ever show
weakness and you ever give the
impression that coexistence is
impossible and that you're going to back
away and give up on your values
then you show something that gives
terrorist hope and we must not do that
you know hearts are broken but our
resolve must be unbreakable
a life has been tragically destroyed but
our values our democratic values they
are indestructible and we must show that
now
if you were in government now would you
consider for example you as a former
prime minister i think
are entitled to close protection i
bodyguards and so on
would you
favor
making that possibility available to
members of parliament now
yes because if there is a risk to
anybody who is a member of the general
public or a member of parliament
and the risk is apparent to the police
authorities
they will do everything in their power
to protect that person and i think what
the speaker is doing and harriet
harmon's called for a speaker's
conference on this
is absolutely right we must say to
members of parliament of course be
careful where you hold your constituency
surgeries in a place that is protected
but at the same time if you need police
protection uh that is going to be
available
and it need not be obtrusive it need not
be so obvious but i think the protection
has got to be made available now to
members of parliament who feel that
there is a risk to what they are doing
and i think that will be introduced in
the next few days
one of the things that i imagine that
david david amerson we both knew him
well would probably be saying
though
he's a man of great compassion kindness
and
if this had happened to somebody else he
would be the first to express his sorrow
but he i guess he would also be saying
that
events should not come in
the way of uh public servants
continuing to do
what the important things they need to
do looking after their constituents and
i want to talk to you about one of the
human issues that you've raised which is
of course
the impact of covert particularly in
developing countries
when we last spoke which is back in june
uh you
said that there were millions of doses
of uh vaccines which you thought should
be shipped to developing countries uh
were sitting in storehouses in europe um
where are we on that now
but you're right to ask this question
because
we've got a detailed report appearing
tomorrow
that shows there are 240 million
vaccines
that are lying in europe and america
that are unused not likely to be used
for months many of them may go to waste
and that would be criminal which could
immediately be airlifted out to those
countries where the level of vaccination
is so low
that not even the nurses and doctors are
protected and certainly not the elderly
vulnerable
and you know boris johnson promised at
the g7
that he was going to vaccinate the whole
world he made this bold announcement
that by next year everybody would be
vaccinated who was an adult in the
developing world as well as the
developed world
but since then so little has happened
that we now face the possibility that
every
target is being missed 10 percent by
september missed 40 percent by december
likely to be missed 70 by next year
likely to be missed and so we've got to
take action immediately
to use these unused vaccines
to save lives you know 100 000 lives
have been saved in britain because of
100 million vaccines how many more lives
can be saved in the rest of the world if
we get these vaccines to people who need
them
you um
if i may
say so you used the word criminal there
in an answer which you also refer to the
prime minister
why do you think this hasn't happened
is it just incompetence or is there
something deeper going on here
i i i was talking about neglect
uh and i do think that this is a lack of
coordination
if president biden boris johnson or sula
van laden at the european union
justin trudeau if they came together
they would find that they had these
unused vaccines
that they're not going to use them even
after all the boosters they are excess
vaccines that are not going to be used
and they should get them out as quickly
as possible
and month by month this number of ex
extra vaccines will grow
another 200 million next month 200
million by the end of the year a billion
in total by january now we've got to get
them to the people who need them
otherwise
people will say
that the neglect is unacceptable if a
hundred million or so vaccines as we
predict go to waste because they pass
the use by date this is the biggest
public policy failure at an
international level for years
outside their war in peace time and
really to save hundreds of thousands of
lives by using the vaccine the miracle
of which is available to us
is something that needs the coordination
of the leaders only they can release the
vaccines not the imf or the world health
organization the leaders have got to
make that decision they ordered the
vaccines they over-ordered and they can
now make them available
if i recall correctly when we discussed
it before actually on the
very day
i think that the president of the united
states was calling a meeting
of uh his fellow g7 leaders to do
exactly what you've just said
why didn't that
happen i mean why didn't we hear more
about that
well i think it was a tragedy that the
meeting
went round the table i don't think boris
johnson was there from the information
that i have although he was down to
speak as right at the beginning of the
event it went round the table people
made promises but they didn't add up to
being enough to get the vaccinations to
people at the time that they needed them
and so we have promises about next year
and we have some vaccines going this
year but we'll never meet the 40 target
unless we take action now and that's an
airlift it needs an airlift now
boris did you say that boris johnson
wasn't in the room when they were
talking about this
well downing street has refused to
confirm that he was there and yet he
made the promise that he was going to
get the world vaccinated and the big
summit that was to be held and was held
under the office of president biden if
as people are saying he did not attend
then i think he's better answer to the
house of commons about why a promise was
made at the g7 that he was going to
oversee and then when it came to the
meetings that had to deal with at a
vaccine summit including the secretary
general of the united nations president
of the european union uh the prime
minister of canada everybody else was
there prime minister draghi of italy
we have to ask what role did he play in
that summit
can i just uh briefly return to the uh
issue of this morning
and ask you about the tone of politics
right now
i spoke both to the home secretary and
to lisa nandy about this and both of
them
i think seem to
confirm what a lot of people are saying
that
without wanting to trace this particular
event to
uh you know the wider
political discourse that there is some
an edge an unpleasantness a coarseness
that's entered
uh political speech and debate
which uh
from their point of view we could well
do without what is your view
yeah i think you can disagree without
being disagreeable and i think
you can have discord without having
malice
and too often i think political
arguments descend
into personal
attacks and personal
conflicts
and i think when it comes to the social
media we've got to look again at the way
these algorithms are organized
because they push people towards the
most extreme positions
and and the media looks to me like a
shouting match without an umpire but the
most extreme positions are the ones that
come across
now this is i think partly because of
the way that um the different media
organizations organize their information
and i think something's got to be done
to look at
online harm that is resulting from this
so yes we've got to clean up here but
let us also remember that if this is a
terrorist incident
we are dealing with a group of
terrorists or group
around a terrorist
who believe that coexistence with the
west is impossible
and we have got to show by the strength
of our democracy and the strength by
which we reach out to other countries
and call for cooperation that this is
not the way that we see the world and
this is not the way the world has got to
be
terrorism has got to be fought directly
head-on
gordon brown thank you very much indeed
thank you